[Musique]
alors un peu de films aussi que j'adore
un autre style c'est un film américain
c'est même d'ailleurs il ya eu une
trilogie c'est la trilogie des before
sunrise et before sunrise parle d'un
américain un jeune américain qui
rencontre une française à vienne est ce
que j'aime beaucoup avec ce film aussi
c'est que c'est vraiment une comme un
rite de passage et une rencontre au
voyage c'est à dire ces deux personnes
qui sont tellement différentes l'une de
l'autre se retrouve dans un train et
décide de passer la journée ensemble
et puis de cela arrive une très grande
histoire d'amour une belle rencontre une
belle réflexion aussi sur ce qu'est
l'amour la vie en général on va vous
posiez de les jeunes d'avoir des cheveux
gras
pas
et tout ça à travers cette espèce de
parcours initiatique temps viennent des
deux personnages principaux qui sont
interprétés par julie delpy et fanuc
exact est vraiment exceptionnel et donc
j'ai choisi before sunrise parce que
c'est le premier mais j'aime aussi
beaucoup les deux suivants puisque a eu
toute une trilogie before succèdent qui
se passe à paris et before midnight se
passe en grèce
[Musique]